I'm still Brisbane is crazy
welcome back to terminus man the game
been updated again so I thought we gonna
check it out play around have some fun
you know not that kind of fun
all right let's do back ways and then
back that's what she said oh sorry I'm
sorry I have a bad hair day don't judge
it
okay Taffet your hair looks great though
like like the video really game like the
video alright so here yet damn it Aaron
Paul Hollywood superstar going to his
next Hollywood acting shoot but Aaron
you're clearly not paying attention to
the road Aaron oh the car don't worry
about it Aaron Paul can't afford any car
T legs
isn't that right Aaron Aaron where when
a job Aaron Paul does his own stunts
he's not like those fake Hollywood stars
there we go now we're talking oh yeah go
ahead go yes Aaron what does he do
anything Harun I'm not gonna do you in
the back
come on babies anyway shut up fire let's
get a faster vehicle why don't we there
we go yes yes yes [ __ ] knows damn it
Aaron [ __ ]
I didn't think this one through I think
skate skate skate skate ereira and see
see you later Aaron he wasn't good and
for me come on iron you can do it yeah
shake that booty for me girl yeah yeah
come on iron you can do it I have 100
percent fit a lucky full of fate I 100
percent gap someone stole your car Aaron
that's kind of 140 I'm so shiny
hahaha you shall never be a swinger oh
la la let's try a different pose oh my
oh why have I not seen this before
that is amazing ooh ooh I like this
position I am taking an arrant vagina
right now it's coming I'm from Aaron's
for Jonah
I heard an explosion and I'm dead follow
the position I'm [ __ ] waiting beach
he always knows how to seduce me you
shall not bow okay maybe add maybe you
can't part still fabulous tale Oh Vespa
Vespa oh you love it best don't you no
no Aaron what have I told you oh god
Aaron Byron he's crazy
oh my god you like it don't you [ __ ]
that's right you like it you [ __ ]
hahaha this game is amazing all right
let's go like this I woke up black hole
what
Yammy stem fabulous dammit
Paul what are you doin full speed
oh yeah baby don't lose yeah you're
gonna die Paul I'm sorry boss the phone
oh yeah so boss let's see his sexy poses
the flying chicken yes the sister me
lady there I'm about to take a [ __ ] on
your lawn if you don't be a better
neighbor let's go with that one
Gopal Gopal Singh we can brush gopal
'gopal
go you piece of [ __ ] Gopal go pod go
putt see you whispers come on come on
damn it
pop what are you even doing pop charity
'save is lahat he's dead he's [ __ ]
dead [ __ ] love this game it big air
camp oh oh my god oh my freakin get go
Bob full sweet oh god no oh ah yeah
you'll die more if you actually make the
jump all idiot and someone's like he
doesn't want to die I don't understand
yeah I'll go Paul go go Paul ah ha oh
well at least the bike made it you know
bait yes yes yes what come on oh yes lil
you lost your little shoe oh I know he
lost his new shoe
oh it's a platter what base shoes are
totally fine
what then what then who is shoe
oh no Aaron policy is late for this next
video shoot and better take the shirt
cat baby
well that was interesting
Erin : is life is it's late for his next
house [ __ ] damn Aaron Thor is late for
his next video shoot here we'll have to
take the shirt K going damn it don't
look at me like Jagger and I tried
everything I could
Aaron's had to be like no it's a flying
Aaron card it's not everyday you see
that go oh Jesus now laced blaze
perfectly still Aaron why did I tell you
I told you to lay still damn it go Aaron
go Aaron a minute go ahead you can see
now you're fogging I'm sorry
still twerking not really he said that's
when you know we did the head
the doctors are like he stopped working
my job is done I'm sorry hahaha
is that a bird is that a plane no it's
an errand pawn go Aaron Paul go Aaron
Paul came in like a wrecking ball Airmen
Power Girl that is also a very great
angle the camera not severe and it loves
your families now go and make me proud
and what is that Aaron Paul just keeps
on rocking maybe it's still on the bag I
repeat he's still on the back got the
flying car Aaron Paul is still on the
back
Aaron Tallis let me shake is he twerking
no he's dead he's dead
we can move on people I press I'm gonna
edit that episode there a lot of foot
playing thank you brother playing with
me today
I saw his bros stay awesome